[inaudible]
wow.
Full House.
It's great to great to be here and
it's real privilege and honor for me to
introduce that then evil now, uh, to uh,
to Google and a two deep mind to come and
talk to us about his amazing new movie
blade runner, 2049. So, um,
I'm sure like many of you,
blade runner is actually one of my
favorite films of all time. Probably my,
my absolute favorite.
And uh,
it's actually one of the main reasons
I got into AI in the first place when I
saw that when I was a
sort of, um, teenager,
young teenager made such
an impression on me. Um,
and how amazing sort of Ai
was portrayed in the film. Uh,
that's why I ended up doing
my whole career on it. And a,
I'm also a huge fan of will work
a sicario arrival prisoners.
I'm sure you've all seen these films.
It's amazing film director, so,
so excited to hear that he was going to,
um,
take the helm for the new blade
runner film. So welcome you. So, um,
how did you approach, you know,
sort of trying to, uh, build,
do a sequel to something that
was so iconic with, you know,
all the legions of fans out
there, something that the,
you know, such big fans of,
how did you approach that?
Well, first of all, I have to see that
before I start. I must say that I'm very,
I feel very on in front of you, everybody,
because you're all experts, you know,
in science is, uh, and, uh, in
the AI, most of you I think, and,
uh, me, I'm just a
filmmaker. I'm just seeing,
I don't think I have
something you, I, I, I can,
I'm happy to be with you to
share my experience about
the making of blade runner
2049 with you today. But I don't think
you will learn anything. And matured.
I'm feeling a bit nervous,
but about, about the, the,
um, no, the, the first of all, when the,
I heard that a Ridley Scott that uh,
and glucose over the Broderick
Johnson from outcome.
We're a bar,
uh,
starting a project that will be a
followup to the first blade runner.
The first time I heard about it, I
said to myself, wow, what an insane,
it's wrong. Beautiful
grade. Bad idea. Yeah.
Because it's like,
as I like you,
the first movies where is by far one
of my favorite one is a movie that is
linked to the my birth of love to cinema.
I mean,
the way I started to
dream to be a director.
So it's like a church,
you know. And uh, um,
and the thing is that what convinced
me was the screenplay when I read the
screenplay, when I had the chance
to read the screenplay, uh,
the screenplay was written at risk
by entered venture was the, the,
the writer of original movie
came with a very strong,
strong ideas, a very strong biome.
And then, uh, uh, and it, it, it,
you work in collaboration with release
holds from the start that secures meal
that the idea that the both
fathers were at the element of the,
of the project.
And then Michael Greene came on board
and made a very strong stream. And, um,
um, from there, uh,
all the pressure was before I
took the decisions because I'm
like, add to talk with Ryan Gosling at
one point that we'll resume the, the, the,
the spirit of the journey's,
uh,
we said to ourselves both to
together at the beginning when,
when decided both to do it is that,
uh,
our chances of success were very narrow.
It was like a,
and to accept that, that, uh,
no matter what we will do,
we knew that we will come be compared
to a masterpiece and a movie that
everybody loved. And, uh, that, uh,
people will come in theaters with baseball
bats, you know, and, and by the way,
if I,
uh,
am a huge fan f if the movie had been
done by someone else, I will add,
I'll be the same and I will
go in there. And, and, um,
knowing that it gave us, and when
you accept that you accept that fate,
then you become free. And,
and, and it's a very, uh,
so you're not bound to success or you're
not thinking about the result you're
taking, thinking about creating
a pure artistic act. And,
uh,
and I think everybody shares the same
pressure on the crew from Roger Deakins to
Dennis Gassner, to all the people
that worked on the movie, that we all
felt that pressure.
And the other on the way to work on that
with that pressure was to get rid of it
by,
by accepting that fact.
How much creative input did he
have once the filming style?
Uh, you, at the beginning, it
was supposed to direct it and,
and it didn't for a simple reason is that
he was too busy. He has a schedule, a,
uh, a lot of projects
in his mind. And, uh,
and the other way on the other
end Arison for, let's face it,
there's no spring chicken. I
mean, he's like, he wanted to, uh,
shoot soon.
You know,
Andy [inaudible],
the sprinkler was ready. Arison
loved the screenplay. And,
and so that's where I came on board.
And so the input or of release is huge
because he created the screenplay.
He wrote the screenplay with the Hampton
and Michael. So that's huge, you know,
and, and, uh, is a, at the birth
of the ideas. So their mom,
they're from there. When I met
him an immediate to get on board,
I needed his blessing. That was one of
my, let's say, conditions to get on board.
I need, I need meet the man, look at
him in the eyes and say, is it okay?
Because, and, and, and I was
very gracious, very a gentleman,
very,
um,
uh,
you welcome me. Uh, says, uh,
that he was happy that I
will do it. And He, um,
uh,
basically gave me all the
elements that, uh, the genesis,
what was behind the first
movie. We're all, all the, the,
the source of inspirations,
the background,
the context of the first
movie and, and what, uh,
what was behind it. And, uh, but
for this one, he said, it's yours.
You're totally free. If you need me, I'll
be at the end, at the end of the phone.
But otherwise, I, I,
uh, you're totally free.
He gave me what we say in French catalog.
Launch means it's my movie.
It's my responsibility. So if
you don't like, is it my fault?
It has nothing to and,
and uh,
the only way I was able to work
is to work with Ridley B and me.
We'll let been totally impossible.
We've always away at the time,
I think it was doing primitives very far
away. I was very, the only way it was, uh,
that, uh, I'm very grateful because
that was very generous of him.
So did he already have this idea in mind
when he was doing the original film or,
or of a sequel or what the sequel would
be about or when did that come about?
I heard different stories about that.
I know, I remember he told me that, uh,
at one point,
you know,
the original blade runner was born at
the time where there was star wars and
Indiana Jones,
all the birth of those sequels.
And I know that really was like a really
loved the first hours and you will,
in fact, it was traumatized
when you saw it was like, Oh
God, it's so good. It's so,
yeah.
Um,
I think the idea,
there was an idea at the time that it
could have done a SQL with that character.
He was seeing, he knew that
the universe was, was bigger.
It's just that the way or the production
and the, there was, it was not possible.
It just took the skills of a producer,
the outcome to be able to,
it was like basically
the rights of the movie.
We're in that kind of
no man's land war zone.
It actually put it all together yet to,
it was a kind of,
what process did you go through to make
it your own universe and your own story.
And that's the thing is that it's,
it was where it took a lot of time
and meditation to be able to make my,
uh, you know, it's a thing to
make a movie. It's a lot of work,
but to take someone else's dream,
to take someone else's characters
to aesthetics, it's like a,
so the way to do it,
it's like I started by saying to myself,
it was a 2049 as I kind of love
letter with the original blade runner.
I mean, I, um, we decided that, I say we,
because I started that right at the
beginning to work with Roger Deakins.
I brought in on board quite early this
time because I was doing finishing
arrival at the time and I needed
this input is a wisdom is uh,
his ideas right at the start.
It was such a huge task.
So I needed a close partner
from the start and uh,
we spent several weeks in Montreal
in a hotel room with a storyboard,
artists to start to draw
to, to, to interpret,
to transform the screenplay into a,
into a movie there together.
So I will say that it's by far a very, the
movie you, I was denied from the start,
you know, it's a very, very strong input
in the movie. Um, the idea was that,
uh, I, uh, when you are, uh, uh, with the,
I'm working with someone whose story,
I always try to find an intimate
way to get into the story too,
to have to create an intimate
link. And one of them, it's,
it's going to sound trivial for you,
but it was huge for me too to
aesthetically it was the climate and the
screenplay was different than the
first movie. It was more like a,
there was the idea that uh,
they will be snow,
it will be winter will be present.
And I mean,
I mean as a Canadian there's one thing I
know about this that they can deal with
and it, it has a strong influence
and strong impact on the line,
right on the atmospheres
and, and, and the two.
So to approach Ridley's universe
through the lens of something that is so
familiar to me, it helped
me to, to define, uh,
what I will keep from the first movie
and what I will answer and what I will
create different to make it my own. And
climate was a strong thing, I will say.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean it has such a strong
style. The first deadline, I mean,
one of the landscape.
Then one thing I always found interesting
about it was this juxtaposition
between very modern technology.
Obviously the replicants
themselves flying cars,
but also combined with quite
old technology like pay phones.
And even the void camp machine
was very analog, right?
So there was a sort of
combination of analog,
quite old things and very modern things.
As I was doing the movie,
sometimes I was feeling I was more doing
a period movie then the Scifi movie
because you guys are so ahead,
you make our lives very difficult
to, it's iPhone. It's like it's a,
it's very often and there's a lot of uh,
uh,
work that is done to date that is virtual,
that it's abstract that
for story telling and the,
and the also technology make a job.
The detective stories quite
boring, you know, okay,
I'm going to find something to take
a keyboard. And Yeah. So it's like,
it's like we need that.
There's nothing more boring for director
then to shoot a character in front of a
screen. Yeah. As I can. So the
screenwriter, I had the brilliant idea.
Uh, I thought, uh, I love
this idea because it,
it created a landscape that allowed
me to create a, an adventure,
which is that it's the thing that
I can talk about is that in the,
in between the first movie, in the
second one, there was an event, uh,
emp that created a blackout,
which is that you many dealers that data,
they lost the,
the digital world went to,
I'm sorry guys,
but
it happened.
So the, the, there was the,
the, the world. In 2014,
we went back to analog technology.
So we went back to the analog world.
Where would they rely on, on, on, on,
on the, on the real, I'm concrete,
not concrete. So what's, is
there a concrete translator?
Something that tangible, tangible
technology, analog technology.
And that for me was a blessing because
it allowed my character to travel,
to open doors, to rooms, to meet people.
I got away from the screen.
From the screen. Yeah. Yeah.
That's fantastic. And, uh, I'm,
I'm about to make another Scifi movie
and my goal is to try to avoid screens
again. So just to be in contact
with the reality more. Yup.
Fantastic.
So another really important,
I think I'm sort of pillar
of the atmosphere in the
first film was the music,
you know, the, I think the Vangelis score
was kind of an amazing score and, and,
and now she created a part,
a lot of the feeling of the film.
How did you approach that
very,
very important element that it was
such a iconic score because it's,
it's a, it was like, you know,
the landscape that we also in the,
in the first movie war, so
this topic, this topic and,
and Dystopian and a dark and depressive,
but on top of it, you had that beautiful
melancholic, Voitric, very delicate music,
you know, with those, uh,
dark spectral drums that were like a,
created a kind of religious feeling
on top of it. And that is, uh, um,
we did a lot of exploration, a lot of
exploration with music. But, uh, you know,
when you do a blade runner movie,
you cannot go very far from the CSAD,
which is the original synthesizer
that Angulus use. I know.
And I insisted and I,
it's the thing that I,
at one point I had to put
my feet up. I said, okay,
we are going in that direction
as much as Roger and I, um,
we are Roger Deakins
and I, we tried to, uh,
make sure that some part of the movie
will be very close as typically to the
first movie because
it's still a detective,
Phil Moss Astarita Blade runner movie.
You have to be in that kind of
zone aesthetic zone and, and,
and is the same for the sound.
So we work very hard to create that
sound soundtrack that will be as close to
the sound effect, the big
like in the, so first one.
And then the same time to have that kind
of Melancholia that is so beautiful and
that very specifics on those,
those cs 80,
there are beast and they are like really
impressive machines. Very delicate.
And um, I'm very proud of the score. I'm a
see, that's the thing that, uh, you know,
when you make a movie, I just
finished a movie few, few weeks ago,
have no distance, but, um,
there's some elements of it that,
and I know that the score, the Benwell
efficient and Zimmer did a fantastic job.
Yeah.
I can't wait to hear that.
So sounds like you're a big
fan of science fiction. I mean,
you say you're doing another
science fiction film, but,
uh, it's interesting that,
you know, as a, as an AI
practitioner, you know,
often in films portrayal of Ai and
robots is usually sometimes negative and
antagonistic.
You know,
some notable exceptions like the robots
in interstellar tars and case they were
fantastic.
So I hope you produce some films with a
positive image of AI in the future. But,
uh, yeah, but with the original,
yeah. But with industry,
with the original blade runner were, you
know, the replicants where, you know,
maybe they were the heroes of the film.
I was always thinking,
do you feel like Ruca Hauer and boy
batsis carrots? It was actually the hero
Ding that I think is, uh,
um, make the people, uh,
got the people confused about the first
finish that Harrison Ford who was at the
time and solo in Indiana. John was
not a hero. It was a dark antihero.
And then that was like very confusing for
people and that, uh, uh, no difficulty.
The replicants are, they are a mirror
of ourselves, you know, they are like,
they represent our anger to
our, our maker, you know,
about our human condition.
Yeah.
You know, I think one of the things
that we all fell in love with it,
the first blade runner and,
and I'm sure you're continuing the you
felt is it's not really a film about
technology in some ways,
right?
It's actually about philosophy and deeper
things like consciousness, identity.
Um, and you know what it
means to be alive. Mortality.
I think that's what it is.
It's, it's a, it's a, um, I
wouldn't say that, uh, again,
uh, that, uh, we, we respected that,
that spirit in the second one. It's like
the, the technology is there to, uh,
create a more dynamic story, but it's not
a, it's not, um, in the foreground at all.
Uh, it's, uh, I will say it's,
it's a, it's there to be exciting,
but still the core of the
movie's about humanity,
what it means to be a human or as human
in some ways we are program ourselves
from our, um, education and,
and from our agentic
background and the owl,
can we get free and, uh, out, uh,
can we get out of the
road? Can we, can we,
can we get free and get rid
of that background and get,
I have more freedom, you know, and
that's the way I see the movie right now.
Movies about broken dreams too, which
is very melancholic and uh, yeah,
it was a beautiful Megan.
Kalia that,
that was the main thing I was trying to
protect, but to have the same kind of, uh,
yeah. Beautiful. See,
yeah. I mean the, the, the, the blade
runner seems to suggest that, um,
the difference between replicants
and humans was sort of the emotional
empathetic side.
Right.
And that's how I do have memories
and having episodic memory,
a memory of your past.
Uh,
and I guess another thing it seems to
suggest was that the longer the replicants
lived, the more emotions
they would sort of develop.
So hence the termination date. But,
um, you know, what if, I don't,
if you're exploring this in the new fan,
but what if they do live longer and they
do develop emotions and feelings and
empathy, would there be much difference
in your opinion then of you know,
retiring a replicant and killing a human?
Yeah,
but the thing is that, uh, if in
the first movie that the, the,
the thing is that they were,
they were the,
the fact that they had a
little short term life,
they developed a anger toward
them, their maker. And the,
in the second movie I can say that,
uh,
of course like the
screenwriter used to say to me,
it's like if a company developed an
iPad that was able to kill people, you,
you will try to find a solution
before selling another high patio.
You will try to find out a
new way to create. So, so
the, the definitely the, the,
the, the, they are new replicants
and their movie that I'd been, uh,
with a longer lifespan
because if you think about it,
if they didn't have a longer lifespan,
30 years later,
there will be no more more problems.
So it means that the ad,
the ad created a new line
of replicants with, uh, uh,
longterm, uh, and that,
uh, but what that was not,
that didn't solve all the problems.
And because there's always
that strong pressure,
that strong [inaudible]
that came from a conditions.
So if you're human or bioengineer human,
you are still dealing with this fact
that you don't know why you are on place.
And, uh, and the fact
that the basic, the also,
there's another factor is that
they replicants are designed to be,
they are basically designed
to be slaves. So the, the,
I think that in the second movie
is more about being citizens, uh,
considered as a real citizens.
That is one of them. The
main topic of, yeah, yeah,
yeah. So it, so as an artist,
you do you feel that there are some
aspects of humanity and being human that
could never be simulated,
uh,
artificially,
would you say
helped me.
Okay.
Uh, it's, it's, um, you know, it's like,
it's like the complexity of humanity
that, uh, uh, that struggle too,
uh, to, uh,
get rid of the voices that
are coming from, uh, the past.
You know, that I think we can't recreate
with an AI that, uh, that, that,
uh, the fact that, uh,
my weakness right now,
how do you recreate that? And those
weakness are very complex products
of my,
the education I received them
from what the experience,
the gift that I received from
the parents to the generation,
the generations, you know? Yeah.
That had to be held your problem.
Okay. So one, one of the, I
mean, I think the last scene of,
of, uh, of blade runner was one of
my, I mean, probably one of the,
I would say one of the greatest teams in
all of cinema, uh, with, with Roy Batty.
And He, you know, he house
sort of releases the delve
into the air as he dies.
Do you think, what do
think that symbolizes? I
always thought that symbolized that
the applicant felt he had a soul.
Is that what you read? That's the
way I read it through. And it's a,
it's a beautiful, uh, uh,
it's a beautiful image image.
And what I love also about this image
is that it came from Rutger Hauer. Yeah,
I love it.
I love it when actors bring strong,
strong ideas on, on the, uh,
when an actor is like [inaudible]
and golf like totally, uh,
that, uh, in position of his, uh,
his character in all good actors,
strong actors,
they can become and they brings
strong ideas. And I had the same, uh,
experience with Ryan Gosling,
brought some very strong ideas on the,
on the, there are some scenes
that I'm very proud of them.
The scene in the movies that honestly,
uh,
one of my best cover it seen as
a Ryan Gosling idea. You know,
your actors to improvise.
I deeply love it.
I love when I'm from the
documentary where, uh,
the thing I love about documentary is
like you put your camera in life and
suddenly sometime life organizes itself.
There was an accident in front
of the camera to create a strong
cinematic moment in from a cinematic
poetry in front of the camera. And I,
that we, I, I find it
back in the fiction is a,
with actors and there's nothing more
exciting for me than when an actor come on
set and say, I didn't sleep,
had this idea and I have this,
I have to try this idea that I love.
Yeah. And I know that there is that same,
which Roger Deakins we,
we tried to create to be ready.
We had, the movie is very a
storyboard. Everything is planned,
but we always keep a space and set to
make sure that the actors have the space
to recreate something
that was not planned,
that the would always link with
the scene of course. But it's,
there's nothing more
exciting for me than that,
than an idea that was not
expecting that surprise me. That's,
I call it the chaos of life.
You know that and it's like,
that's why I think that
computer generated the uh,
characters are always,
most of the time they are created by
people be on the camera that they don't
have.
They cannot create that spontaneous,
those accidents that brings
sparks of life and the surprise.
And that's why we are where
we are becoming. So, uh,
uh, surprise and excite the,
as an audience member that we,
that's why he snuck and evolve.
That's where cinema can evolve this when
we catch live in front of the camera.
And now there's some
moments like that in the,
in the several moments
like that in Berlin,
blade runner 2049 and those are
going to that by favorite ones.
I can't imagine that film with that route
to have a sort of and providing those
last lines. I think those words. Exactly,
exactly. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. And that's one of, one of the
reason why also I love real sets,
real an environment that we constructed
the sets and stimulates that and the
actor's actor can focus on
is the interior and not on,
I'm not trying to imagine and to be in
relationship with something that is a
virtual. Yeah. That's why I had not like
green screens. I like real environments.
Yeah. Fantastic. Well, we should,
I'm sure there's many a
questions from the audience.
We should open it up to the audience
for questions. Please. I should be,
we should have some mics around the place.
So
am I allowed to ask a question
about arrival? Yes, I think so.
Um, so, uh, uh, so yes, yes, yes, yes.
So arrival, uh, amazing.
That was my baseball,
but moment,
uh,
the tet young short story stories
are alive is so, so impactful,
so beautiful. And I wanted
to, but it's so tied up in,
in language and the written word
and the way that he sort of,
I don't know if everybody I know who's
read it yet, but go read it. It's awesome.
Um, the way it's tied up in
language and the written word is so
complicated.
How did you approach turning the story
of time and language and how it affects
the mind into something
that you could put on screen
when you, when you do an adaptation? Um,
it's a very violent, violent
process. You need to, to, uh,
there's a brutal moment when you need
to destroy the original that the,
I don't know if you read all the short
story from touching the story of your
life. It's a little masterpiece.
It's a gem. And as you rightly said,
it's like the,
we play with language and time and
it's so beautiful and so clever and so
brilliant to do a movie out of
it. It's like, it's like a, um,
first of all, I, uh,
what I read it and, uh,
produce referred me to, uh, to add up. Uh,
I didn't knew how to because it
felt like, um, I said to them,
it's like a fantastic story
and there's a movie there,
but our,
because it's a story about the process
of a repetitive process and intellectual
process and uh, and uh, to find a
cinematic structure out of this.
It took a screenwriter,
Eric Icer that came on
board and created the Uhm,
that find this idea of creating a tension
but the tension that was making it
maybe more accessible story and um,
that was the key.
Then, uh, um, the rest is a, is a,
was a long process to, uh, to,
to the, the challenge of this,
this movie was really to make sure that,
because basically it's a teacher that
makes students, you know, and the,
they are teaching a language together.
So I'll do make this like a dynamic story
that will not feel repetitive and that
will stay.
Uh,
it took a long time in
the screenwriting process,
even in shooting and the movie transform
itself, not the main story, but the,
the process to find the right rhythm, the
right elements. It was a, there is no,
it's not a simple question. It's, it was
a puzzle to make them by far the longest,
uh, editing, uh, sessions of my life,
the most complex sessions and the, no,
it was not a given at the beginning.
It was very, very difficult
movie to do. Yeah.
We'll say bye. But that's a very
huge compliment coming. Thank you.
Thank you.
Viral,
I believe at least six different cuts of
the original blade runner with in some
cases they'll just be different at digs.
Did that make to your sequel difficult?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. To make a,
Yep. That's a good question.
The thing is that, uh,
basically two between both fathers,
you know, because I listen for them.
[inaudible] they still don't
agree about that. They still, uh,
I found the,
the,
the answer and a Phillip k Dick
Novel where the characters,
I love the idea of, uh, they are
doubting about themselves, the cups,
the blade runners in the
Philip k. Dot. Dick novel.
There are some time saying to themselves,
maybe I should do the do the wife came
from myself because this morning I'm not
sure if I'm human or not. You know,
it's like the, and I love this idea.
I love the idea of keeping the question
alive to stand and walk the fine line,
fine line of the doubt.
And it's the thing that reassure me and
to start amped and venture wrote a story.
The story of a 2049 is, is um, basically,
uh, walk on this line is
decorated as a replicant or not.
And I love the fact that the e s the
state on the question and not giving any
answers, so it's, um, it's
released. God was sitting here,
it will look at me and said, what the
hell he's talking about because he,
he but me. I love the fact that, uh,
the care does doubting about his own
identity even in is and isn't sure about
that. That I love that. For me it's like
what does the part of the movie's about?
Yeah.
And then I was one of the questions I
want most wanted to ask you that she was,
could you came up the third tier?
You know, mystery I had of when I,
when I used to spend hours arguing with
my friends about was Deckerd a replicant
and, but then the director's cut
seem to confirm in my opinion,
for sure with the dream of the Unicorn
in his dream. And then they will unicorn,
you know, Origami. So are you,
are you going to answer that?
But then you show an age,
Irish and Harrison Ford.
So then now it seems to suggest either
the replicants can age or, or, uh,
he's not rapidly, you have
to watch the movie. Yeah.
Right. So Do, do you actually answer
it all right? We, how can I say?
The thing is that honestly, it's a thing
I can see without giving any spoilers,
is that I think that, uh, again,
questions create vertigo questions.
Like why I love one of the reasons
I love Scifi because it's like, it,
it allows you in a very dynamic,
dynamic way to approach
existential questions are rubbish.
Okay. And, and, and, uh,
those existential question brings
you in contact with the unknown,
which creates a beautiful vertigo.
And the, the question of the,
the I love this feeling and it's
decorated as a human or not for me.
I love the question.
The answer is less interesting.
Yeah. You want to keep the tension.
Yeah. Yeah. She has a big part of it.
I read with views that Harrison Ford
and obviously it's famously, you know,
he apparently didn't like the original,
but is it just the different
interpretations of the original? Was that,
what was the argument about or,
cause presumably he does like
it cause I think that if,
if a Irisin from a 100 students,
and I don't want to
put words in his mouth,
but if you are asking me what,
from what I understand is
that if felt that a man,
a human being falling in love with,
with uh,
an artificial human being was quite
poetic and strong and beautiful and rose a
lot of questions, then
two androids, androids,
but to replicants falling in love,
wanting to effect it was less
interesting for him. The idea that the,
and I think that when he,
for him,
when he shot the movie as an actor,
he played it as a human. I mean,
he has a different reaction. He has a,
he's like a, he has different qualities.
He has different, uh, and it was very,
and it drove him through all this.
So when he learned later that he was
maybe a replicant, I think it's a what
and the
still to this days, but me,
I love the together. I mean,
I think the other tough shoot. Yeah. I
think that the deeply respect each other.
Yeah. And, and, uh,
maybe that tension is what
made it so great actually.
Tension between agree. Yes.
Yes, definitely. Well, listen, that, I
think that's all we got time for today,
but I'm so looking forward to seeing the
new film and maybe getting some answers
or some more questions. Thank
you everybody. Thank you.
[inaudible].